last November authorities in Bosnia and
had to Governor confiscated and
destroyed nearly two and a half thousand
illegal Firearms at a factory outside
Sarajevo
in recent months more weapons and parts
have been melted down in these furnaces
officials say they want to reduce the
number of illegal weapons kept by their
citizens
the estimates we operate with show that
approximately 750
000 Firearms are kept by citizens of
Bosnia and Herzegovina and some recent
studies speak of eight hundred thousand
Security Experts say this represents a
grave security threat not only for
Bosnia and Herzegovina but for Europe as
well
there's increased concern following two
mass shootings in neighboring Serbia
earlier this month that killed 18 people
including students at a primary school
in Belgrade
perhaps with the help of our
International Partners primarily the
European Union we should address this
issue and use a regional approach to
solving this problem
the European Union recently held a
Regional Conference on Firearms control
it's promised more than 4.3 million
dollars in new funding to help Regional
countries crack down on illegal weapons
our world will make Europe safer
and this becomes more important in the
challenges time in which we are living
European leaders saying they're also
working on ways to prevent arm smuggling
Remain the midterm review of the road
map shows more needs to be done for
example on awareness racing reducing
illegal possession and the diversion of
legal weapons into illegality
every one out of five people in Bosnia
and Herzegovina reportedly owns an
illegal weapon citizens can now turn in
their firearms without facing any
criminal charges
the Western Balkans region has been
struggling with illegal weapons since
the war and unrest of the 1990s
but officials in Bosnia and Herzegovina
are hoping to change that through
programs like these
Michael Apple Al Jazeera